il ya quelques mois la commission
européenne m'a contacté en me demandant
si ça me tentait de parler des e2c sur
ma chaîne c'est les écoles de la
deuxième chance
c'est une initiative dans la commission
européenne est à l'origine et qui vise à
réintégrer les français qui sont sortis
du système de l'emploi pour différentes
raisons notamment le décrochage scolaire
et là je me suis rendu compte que je
connaissais très mal ce que l'europe
pouvait faire pour favoriser l'emploi
des jeunes en france il ya pas mal de
choses qui gagne à être connu et qui
vous intéresseront sûrement
et donc c'était l'occasion d'en faire un
sale jeudi je préfère vous préciser tout
de suite ça n'a absolument rien changé à
la manière avec laquelle se sache ce qui
a été écrit c'est à dire libre et avec
son esprit critique et ça m'a même fait
plaisir parce que l'europe est souvent
attaqué sur youtube et on a vu pendant
les dernières élections qui soit sur
internet ou via les discours et
réflexions de certains candidats qui
commençait à y avoir un fort sentiment
anti européen
attention je pas là pour vous dire que
l'europe c'est une entité parfaite sur
tous les points et qu'il faudrait vénéré
aveuglément mais franchement je pense
qu'elle nous apporte bien plus que le
fait de pouvoir accéder à de la data
pour choper un hubert pendant que je
peux faire gagner du berghain rien que
le fait que ça ne protège des guerres
intra européenne parce qu'on a presque
oublié que c'était ça me paraît pas mal
donc aujourd'hui je vous parlais du
chômage chez les jeunes en europe et
particulièrement en france des causes
des conséquences et des solutions parce
qu'elle peut être des solutions
sérieuses lee commençons par faire un
point sur la situation en europe selon
eurostat l'office statistique de l'union
européenne en mars 2010 est le taux de
chômage des actifs de moins de 25 ans
s'est élevé à 19 heures que 4% dans la
zone euro et à 17,2 pour cent dans
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
un an plus tôt ses taux s'est élevé
respectivement à 21,3 pour cent et 19 3%
alors on pourrait se dire c'est un super
progrès que tout va bien alors oui parce
que ça va mieux mais non parce que ça va
pas encore bien
ainsi le chiffre s'améliore on a encore
en 2017 un problème de surchauffe maj
chez les jeunes en europe
à titre d'exemple le taux de chômage de
l'ensemble de la population active
c'est 9 5% dans la zone euro alors que
là on se parle de 19 4%
en fait au total dans l'union européenne
c'est 3 millions huit cent quatre-vingt
trois mille jeunes européens qui sont au
chômage alors qu'au même moment
si on regarde chez les parlementaires
européens le taux d'absentéisme est
assez hallucinant c'est même pas moi qui
le dit c'est jean claude juncker alors
en réalité ces chiffres sur le chômage
des jeunes ils cachent des situations
hyper varié entre les pays on a les bons
élèves comme l'allemagne avec
6 7% la république tchèque avec 9 2 3%
ou les pays bas avec 9,6 pour cent et
aussi les moins bons les pays au sud de
la zone euro parce que forcément
puisqu'ils ont connu de fortes
politiques d'austérité ils sont plus
affectés par le chômage des jeunes et
même si elle n'est pas la seule
responsable
l'europe n'est pas pour rien celle qui a
imposé à la plupart de ces pays des
cures d'austérité en grèce
48 % des actifs de moins de 25 ans sont
sans emploi
45 % en espagne ou encore 34 1% en
italie et les chiffres pourraient être
plus élevés si une partie des jeunes
n'avaient pas quitté leur pays d'origine
pour trouver du travail à l'étranger
pourtant et même pour ces pays bien au
dessus du taux moyen la situation semble
s'arranger
pourquoi avoir tout simplement parce que
le taux de chômage chez les jeunes n'a
cessé de descendre depuis 2013 il était
à ce moment là son plus haut niveau à
cause de la crise de 2008 avec un taux
de 23,6 pour cent pour l'union
européenne est de 24 2% pour la zone
euro et c'est pour ça que je parle de
mieux de 2013 à 2017 la grèce passe de
58,3 % à 48 % l'espagne de 55 5% à 42 5%
et pareil pour l'italie qui passe de 40%
à 34 2%
pourquoi eh ben il ya énormément de
raison par exemple l'amélioration
mondial de l'économie ou les mesures
prises par les pays en question mais il
ya une partie des raisons qui à mettre
sur le compte des mesures mises en place
par l'europe on a trop souvent tendance
à l'oublier ou même ne pas le savoir
parce que ces mesures ne sont jamais
financé exclusivement par l'europe
elles sont toujours en cofinancement en
gros c'est un peu comme quand vous
participez dai-ichi pour l'anniversaire
de votre pote jo
vous avez beau mettre 50 balles si la
partipation et anonyme
vous aurez aucune reconnaissance était
2012 en réaction au taux de chômage
dramatique de certains pays la
commission européenne a mis en place une
série de mesures pour faciliter l'emploi
des jeunes et parmi ces mesures on
trouve plusieurs choses
déjà la garantie pour la jeunesse désolé
de décevoir les parents qui me regardent
ça ne servira pas à ramener en magasin
votre gamin défectueux dans un
engagement de tous les états membres
adopté en avril 2013 de proposer aux
jeunes de moins de 25 ans une offre
d'emploi correspondant à leur profil
une formation continue un apprentissage
ou un stage dans les quatre mois suivant
leur sortie de l'enseignement ou la
perte de leur emploi
en plus de cette garantie pour la
jeunesse il est aussi depuis 2013 lit au
gie initiatives pour l'emploi des jeunes
qui est le principal moyen de
financement de l'union européenne pour
faciliter la mise en place de la
garantie en complétant les actions
prises au niveau
nationale elle a été lancée comme une
aide spéciale aux régions où le taux de
chômage des jeunes est supérieur à 25%
vise uniquement les neet not in
education of training les jeunes sans
emploi ne suivant ni enseignement ni
formation ainsi que les jeunes chômeurs
de longue durée et ceux qui ne sont pas
inscrits en tant que demandeur d'emploi
dans la pratique la garantie pour la
jeunesse a considérablement facilité les
réformes de 2013 à 2015 les états
membres ont adopté 132 mesures ciblant
les jeunes sur le marché du travail
vous connaissez j'aime bien quand ça
parle concrètement je veux donner deux
exemples d'abord l'espagne elle a
complètement remanié son programme
d'apprentissage faisant passer le nombre
d'apprentis de 4000 à 5000 en trois ans
et ensuite la finlande qui a instauré
depuis 2015 des guichet unique pour
l'orientation des jeunes
les one stop garden center l'objectif
c'est une orientation et un
accompagnement personnalisé des moins de
30 ans une aide dans la vie quotidienne
un soutien pour élaborer un projet
professionnel et acquérir des
compétences sociales ainsi qu'un appui
en matière d'éducation et d'emploi
et franchement c'est difficile de nier
les résultats comme on le disait tout à
l'heure le taux de chômage chez les
jeunes il a diminué en europe pour
passer de 2013 à mars 2010 est de 23 6%
à 17 2% 2 millions de jeunes chômeurs de
moins environ
alors attention il ya encore une fois
l'europe n'est pas seule responsable
il est nécessaire de replacer ce bourg
est dans le contexte économique global
c'est pas possible de connaître tous les
facteurs d'une baisse du chômage mais la
garantie jeunesse accélère ces
améliorations il ya des chiffres très
concret derrière ça depuis janvier 2014
16 millions de jeunes ont bénéficié des
dispositifs de la garantie pour la
jeunesse et les initiatives pour
l'emploi des jeunes a fourni une aide
directe à plus de 1 6 million de
personnes dans toute l'union européenne
et ça c'est réel alors pourtant
peut-être qu'en tant que jeune chômeur
français vous avez l'impression que
votre situation s est patent améliorer
ça vous avez raison car si on peut
constater une baisse du taux de chômage
chez les jeunes entre 2013 et 2016
plupart des pays européens c'est pas le
cas en france le taux de chômage des
jeunes était de 24 1% en 2013 et 24 6 %
en 2016 plusieurs facteurs du chômage
des jeunes français sont identifiables
vous avez forcément entendu dans divers
médias système éducatif trop généraliste
et pas assez professionnalisant
dénigrement systématique lors du cursus
scolaire depuis
y'a manuel pourtant récherche de main
d'oeuvre manque de places en
apprentissage ou en alternance et des
connexions des formations vis à vis des
besoins des entreprises
je le fais moi-même comment j'aurais pu
faire cette vidéo si on m'avait pas
appris à obtenir un précipité
d'hydroxyde de fer en cours de chimie
c'est notamment pour ça que beaucoup de
jeunes décrochent le système scolaire
n'est pas toujours adapté et le problème
c'est que quand on décroche enfin c'est
très difficile de se réinsérer
en france il y à 150 mille jeunes qui
abandonnent chaque année sans diplôme ni
qualification
alors justement l'europe a co financé
via le fonds social européen
un système qui vient en aide à ceux qui
ont besoin de cette réinsertion
j'en ai parlé en intro c'est les écoles
de la deuxième chance les e2c elle
accueille quinze mille jeunes parents
avec une pédagogie complètement
différente par exemple les profs de
maths montrent des ateliers de cuisine
les profs de français vont écrire des
paroles de rap et en plus il ya un lien
fort avec le monde professionnel
puisqu'il ya des gens du monde de
l'entreprise qui accueille les jeunes
dans leur environnement et leur font
découvrir leur métier et même s'il n'y a
pas de diplômes à la sortie et que le
chiffre en absolu de 15 mille par an et
pas très élevé il a quand même 60 % des
élèves qui enchaîne sur une formation ou
un emploi
donc c'est quelque chose qui marche bien
l'une des autres raisons évoquées pour
expliquer le chômage persistant chez les
jeunes français c'est le manque de
flexibilité du marché du travail
en gros les entreprises ont peur
d'embaucher parce qu'elles savent que
c'est très difficile de licence et
derrière les médias nous compare souvent
au royaume uni le bon élève en la
matière et il faut reconnaître que le
taux de chômage des jeunes y est passé
entre 2013 et 2016 de 20,6 % à 13 %
mais il faut se rend compte que les
résultats du royaume uni sont impactés
par l'émergence des mini jobs temps
partiel contre à zéro heure et autres
contrats d'auto entrepreneur lui
privilégie les sociétés comme hubert ou
des libéraux c'est un phénomène qui se
confirme dans les chiffres il y à 24 2 %
des jeunes en emploi au royaume uni qui
ont signé un contrat de moins de 20
heures contre seulement 9% en france le
problème de ces contrats on n'en parle
pas assez c'est la précarité qu'ils
entraînent d'après les derniers chiffres
disponibles par eurostat qui date de
2015 le taux de risque de pauvreté était
de 13 % en france contre 16,7 pour cent
au royaume uni malgré un chômage plus
faible
et c'est un paradoxe qui s'explique par
le nombre de travailleurs pauvres au
royaume uni plus de 20% des salariés ils
gagnent moins
deux tiers du salaire médian contre 6%
en france principalement des salariés en
contrats temporaires ou à temps partiel
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux être au chômage
ou cumuler plusieurs emplois mal
rémunérés
là dessus le royaume-uni la france
semble avoir fait des choix différents
je disais en début de vidéo que la
situation allait mieux mais pas encore
bien c'est justement pour insister sur
le fait que la situation s'améliore mais
que tout reste à faire et c'est l'europe
l'a bien compris et a annoncé fin 2016
sa volonté d'aller encore plus loin en
matière de lutte contre le chômage des
jeunes pour citer jean claude juncker
président de la commission européenne il
a déclaré en 2016 je ne peux pas
accepter et je n'accepterai jamais que
l'europe soit et reste le continent du
chômage des jeunes que la génération du
millénaire la génération y deviennent
pour la première fois en 70 ans plus
pauvre que celle de ses parents c'est
vrai que c'est un peu relou d'être
obligés d'organiser un dîner chez ses
parents pour ne pas manger des pâtes
surtout quand à 35 ans du coup il ya
deux initiatives centrales qui ont vu le
jour pour compléter la garantie pour la
jeunesse la création d'un corps européen
de solidarité et d'erasmus processus pro
je vous rassure ce n'est pas la version
payante d'erasmus erasmus pour rappel ce
initiative qui a permis à plus de 3
millions d'étudiants et d'étudiantes de
l'échoppé de l'étudier d'aller étudier
un autre pays européen
un au fil du temps l'initiative s'était
ouverte collégiens il c'est un stagiaire
et apprentis et erasmus pro vise à
permettre à 50000 apprentis de bfc de
mobilité longue de 6 à 12 mois dans un
autre pays européen d'ici à 2020 l'idée
derrière c'est de faciliter dès 2017 les
échanges entre apprentis parce que le
situation d'apprentissage peuvent
changer drastiquement d'un pays à
l'autre
le corps européen solidarité ils
répondent à la même logique renforcer la
coopération entre les jeunes des
différents pays européens tout en leur
permettant d'acquérir une expérience
réutilisables ensuite point futurs
entretiens d'embauché l'idée c'est
d'offrir aux jeunes européens la
possibilité de s'engager comme
volontaire de décrocher une bourse un
apprentissage ou un emploi dans des
activités solidaires dans l'ensemble de
l'europe pour une période allant de deux
à douze mois les participants pourront
s'engager dans un large éventail
d'activités tels que l'éducation la
santé l'intégration sociale mais de la
fourniture de denrées alimentaires la
construction d'abris l'accueil l'aide et
l'intégration des migrants et des
réfugiés
la production de l'environnement ou
encore la prévention des catastrophes
naturelles et enfin l'initiative pour
l'emploi des jeunes voit son budget de 6
4 milliards augmenté de 2
car avec pour intention d'aider un
million de jeunes de plus que prévu
d'ici à 2020 donc difficile de dire dans
ces conditions que l'europe ne fait rien
contre le chômage des jeunes voilà en
tout cas j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu et que vous avez appris plein de
choses sur le chômage des jeunes je
remercie la commission européenne de
m'avoir permis de la faire si l'une des
initiatives dont j'ai parlé dans la
vidéo vous intéresse qu'ils s'agissent
d'erasmus ou du corps européen de
solidarité
je voulais ce chèque est la description
j'ai indiqué des liens pour vous
puissiez vous renseigner
c'est des mesures qui ont été mises en
place pour vous c'est gratuit et ça
serait dommage de ne pas en profiter
n'hésitez pas j'ai même mis le script
avec toutes les sources et les notes de
tout ce dont je parle
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à checker ça
non plus pour conclure sur une note
optimiste
le taux de chômage des jeunes en france
d'après les dernières statistiques
eurostat de juillet 2010 est serait en
baisse puisqu'il passe de 24 6 % en 2016
à 23 4% 23 24% et ouais c'est pas trop
cool franchement voilà ce que je jouais
alors un chômage des jeunes à 23 0 4%
une belle leçon stoïcisme n'était pas à
me suivre sur facebook twitter et snap
chat et à partager la vidéo si vous a
plu love peace et on se retrouve pour un
prochain épisode sur ma chaîne